so tell us a little bit about all the
many things that the MBTA does the MBTA
is basic service is it provides 1.3
million trips every day to people
throughout Greater Boston does this
through an extensive bus system for
subway lines a huge commuter rail system
and as well as a handful of ferries how
does the age of Boston subway system
come into play here how does it how does
it matter for you it's really the issue
that you know that our customers care
that the subway and the bus is reliable
and it the age of the system sort of
strikes at the core of that you know we
have we have one rail line with cars
from 1946 we have cars we have cars that
are only twelve years old that are not
performing as well as we'd hoped and it
really affects the reliability of the
system and I think what folks want is a
train or a bus that shows up on time on
schedule and gets them where they want
to go in the amount of time that they've
been told it's gonna take them I think
making investments in the system is the
key to doing that we're bringing in
hundreds of new cars for the red and
orange line and as a consequence the
newer the new technology is going to
require us to upgrade the track and
signals we're gonna get to the point
where probably by 2023 where we can have
three-minute headways on the red line
right now we have four to six minute
headway is at about seventy five percent
reliability I think we can get to three
minute headway is at ninety five percent
reliability so all the way up and down
the red line you're gonna be plus or
minus ninety seconds from a train during
rush hour I think that's a real that's
going to be a real benefit to customers
I also think it's going to bring
marginal customers who might be
considering an alternative mode of
transportation
it's gonna bring marginal customers into
the system so I think these types of
investments are what's going to drive
new ridership and provide better service
to our existing riders and how is this
paid for surely the assembly passengers
can't possibly expect it to pay for the
upgrading of their own service we did
raise fares so they are they are in fact
paying for some of it but we have
capital funding available from the state
through internally generated front funds
and as well as through federal funds
what is interested in reading funds I
mean we essentially have the capacity to
borrow so we borrow to to fund certain
projects one of the
so one think they'll actually be paid
for by future customers is that is that
what they will be if they will be paid
for yes either by they will be paid for
by future customers there's also been
you know there's also been some
dedicated state funding as well that is
going to pay for them this is an area
with the trade-off between rail and bus
becomes quite clear right where you can
clearly do some version of what's going
on these 46 and 56 trains on buses
instead how should I think more
generally about that trade-off in
transportation systems I mean I think
there there there's attractive features
to bus right you have the flexibility to
redesign your system you have the
flexibility to serve populations that
and do it in relatively short order and
we have areas where we are under serving
customers as the Boston area has
developed there's been a bunch of
transportation nodes that have grown I
mean the ones that leap to mind are
particularly north of a city we've big
populations in East Boston and Chelsea
that are using the bus we're trying to
build capacity in that area in terms of
bus stations and you know large
intermodal stations but also supplement
the bus routes on the other hand with
rail you know there is some virtue in
having a fixed rail system particularly
in a congested city center where you can
get people rapidly to to and from a
place and I think as we improve service
we talked about the red line as we
improve service on the red line I think
the benefits of that will become clear
the issue with rail now is construction
costs and available space to actually
build new capacity late night service so
the tea has you know in the past you
know familiar battlecry people who are
much younger than I am was that it's
horrible for Boston that the tea doesn't
run later than it than it does how
should I think about this and what what
changes are made in this area yes the
tea the tea has gone through several
iterations of late-night service and I
think we're still thinking about what
actually makes sense and what there's
actually demand for one of the issues
with the previous late-night service was
there was relatively low demand I think
the one thing that folks don't think
about because they're not you know they
shouldn't necessarily but in a system
with really
unbelievable state of good repair needs
where we have to do so much work on this
system to get it up into condition
running trains until 1:00 or 2:00 in the
morning on a service that opens up at
5:00 a.m. really constrained your window
to do work you also have to think about
what populations you want to serve is
this is this a vehicle to promote
nightlife in Boston or is it for service
workers who have limited transportation
options who need to get to and from
places
you